as cp 682 versus the gate guardian can
the giant warrior with a sword hotter
than the sun finally kill the
hard-to-destroy reptile when scp-682 was
brought in to hopefully meet its
ultimate destruction at the gate the
guardian guards it quipped is this meant
to be the garden
this is not the garden the garden is far
west of here when the gate guardian
struck 682 it was grievously wounded
with only a single leg left as it
regenerated it snarled at the gate
guardians saying die you command me to
die oh wouldn't we all like that but
this is my curse for suggesting the
fruit it struck again and before passing
out from its injuries 682 said
this is not the garden and you are not
uriel pretender
scp-682 vs
scp-702 who would win the hard to
destroy reptile or the gaseous living
embodiment of the trade offer meme let's
find out when the gaseous entity inside
scp-702 suddenly appeared the
researchers offered scp-682 to it as a
gift 702 briefly considered the offer
for around 13 minutes before
disappearing with the monster leaving a
cage with a parakeet in it in return 702
later returned 682 after it ate several
other curious items in its vast
collection considering it to be more
trouble than it's worth something the
foundation can definitely relate to the
parakeet is still kept in dr quater's
office
scp-682 vs scp-507
the hard to destroy reptile versus the
reluctant dimension hopper could this
unlikely hero finally be the one who
gets rid of this cantankerous unkillable
beast
scp-682 was heavily injured to the point
of being immobilized and scp-507 was
tied to its leg in hopes of teleporting
it away eventually both creatures
blipped out of existence 63 hours later
507 returned tied to a creature with
large fangs and vestigial wings but was
otherwise identical to scp-682
507 had a note attached to his chest
reading dear universe 5802 sigma blue
romeo it's your problem now suckers
in an attempt to finally get rid of
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile the
scp foundation considered leaving it
inside
scp-3008 the infinite ikea and just
letting it be their problem for a change
how do you think it worked out the
foundation sealed 682 into a box and
sent it inside of 3008 with an unmanned
drone there was no response for 24 hours
at which point 18 instances of the
malformed ikea staff exited the building
each one carrying a large box stamped
with an ikea logo they set these on the
ground and then headed back inside
inside each of these boxes was a living
part of scp-682
and like all things that come out of an
ikea box 682 had trouble correctly
putting itself back together thankfully
this granted the foundation time to
re-establish containment before scp-682
had the chance to properly regenerate
scp-682 vs scp-532
the hard to destroy reptile seems to
ignore the laws of physics most of the
time but how will he fare when the
foundation uses the scp-536 chamber to
manipulate the laws of physics around it
scp-682's containment tank was moved
into the 536 chamber the speed of light
fundamental charge and nuclear force
were increased progressively over time
the chamber was utterly annihilated in
seconds but even when the process was
done and 682 was reduced to one percent
of its normal size it was still alive
one of the researchers lost it from the
frustration and began turning all the
dials to torture the creature he was
removed from the cross testing room but
was later forgiven for his indiscretions
with his supervisor noting that he would
have done the same seeing as at times
682 seemed almost like it enjoyed the
process
scp-682 vs scp-162
the hard to destroy reptile was brought
in front of the nightmarish contraption
known as the ball of sharp a malevolent
ball of sharp objects that draws its
victims in and tears them apart 682
screamed profanities as it was brought
before the ball it then extended its
deadly hooks tearing off one of 682's
forelimbs and its bottom jaw after a
violent struggle that's when 682 broke
containment dragging 162 along with it
and using it to slaughter 11 different
members of personnel as well as injuring
nearly 90 others two additional deaths
were caused during the recovery and the
researchers who had organized the cross
test were all given a disciplinary
scp-682 vs scp-826
these magical dragon bookends can really
bring fiction to life but could they
make the dream of killing scp-682 a
reality a short story written by a
researcher entitled the generally nice
friendly thing that can and will kill
scp-682 permanently if it so much as
spots that damn lizard which we can
imagine was very cathartic to write was
placed between the book ends a d-class
on a motorcycle lured scp-682 into this
new fantasy world to fight the generally
nice friendly thing and an epic battle
between the two unfolded however when
the battle came to an end 682 lived and
the thing had been torn apart when it
was returned to its containment chamber
the title of the book had become the
generally nice friendly thing that tried
to kill scp-682 permanently but failed
with almost 200 extra pages detailing
the epic but ultimately fruitless battle
scp-682 vs dr bright could this battle
of the immortals finally result in one
of their lives coming to an end let's
find out the plan was to get scp-682 to
ingest dr bright's
scp-963 medallion erasing the beast's
consciousness and replacing it with the
good doctors from there it would
hopefully be a little more cooperative
with attempts to kill it but it didn't
quite work out like that dr bright's
consciousness was at war with the
monsters inside its body after eating
the medallion on the outside 682 grew
giant claws and tunneled out of the
chamber where it ate the feet of one
researcher dr samet thankfully dr bright
was able to escape with his life and
inhabit a new human body but fragments
of his consciousness were left in 682's
malicious brain the foundation once
tried to kill scp-682 the hard to
destroy reptile with scp-272
an old iron nail this anomalous nail can
kill its victims in a number of ways the
nail binds a victim's shadow to the
ground indirectly binding the victim
itself as well by doing so if the shadow
is displaced due to changes in light
source the victim is flung and contorted
in the same direction the shadow has
moved if the victim tries to destroy the
nail they will surely die after the
foundation intentionally made the lights
in 682's chambers strobe on and off from
various directions causing the reptile
to be mutilated by being hurled around
the room its body began producing an
extremely powerful light source
eliminating its own shadow and keeping
it safe the light was so bright that
when d-classes entered the chamber to
remove the nail despite wearing eye
protection they were afflicted with
permanent retinal damage and of course
in the end
scp-682 was just fine the cross test
between scp-682 and scp-173 with high
precision blades was a complete disaster
organized by dr shenron the two iconic
monsters were brought into a test
chamber and the blades were deployed
cutting both of them into pieces two
d-classes were sent in when the vacuum
system failed and were killed by
scp-682's blobs of flesh and the newly
reformed
scp-173 at this point the battle began
and 173 attacked the different blobs of
682 flesh some blobs fought back while
others reformed into a smaller version
of 682 which stared at 173 just like in
the original test a sniper shut out the
eyes of this smaller 682 leading 173 to
snap its neck it then regenerated and
stared at 173 for 17 hours before the
test was finally ended when 173 was
taken back to its cell there was a power
failure in the hallway leading to a
site-wide containment breach and many
deaths in one particularly exciting
cross test the foundation set scp-682
the infamous hard to destroy reptile
against scp-204
a cloud of deadly all-consuming nanites
bonded to a small child for the purposes
of protecting them as scp-682 naturally
attacked the child the nanites sprung
into action forming the shape of a huge
warrior with an axe and shield the
battle was intense but amazingly despite
taking tremendous damage itself the
scp-204 warrior kicked the stuffing out
of scp-682
as is expected of scp-204 its nanites
began feeding on scp-682's immobilized
body but surprise surprise as cp-682
started regenerating faster than the
nanites could eat it it then began to
attack scp-204 once again the foundation
tranquilized both parties and hosed
scp-682 with hydrochloric acid before
returning them both to their chambers
all anomalies contained no children
harmed in one cross test the hard to
destroy reptile scp-682 was made to face
off against
scp-689 the terrifying haunter in the
dark a statue that can induce death in
anyone who looks at it and then stops
paying attention the statue was placed
in 682's chamber and the lights were
turned off for five minutes when the
lights were turned back on 682 laid
motionless in a pile of dark gray goo
when a d-class was sent in to confirm
the kill 682 suddenly rose back up to
its feet and devoured him in an instant
two swift chomps with its razor-sharp
teeth and the d-class was history it
seems that 682 doesn't fit the same
definition of alive as us humans and as
a result was unaffected by the haunter
in the dark frighteningly 682 was also
smart enough to intuit 689's anomalous
ability and use this knowledge to play
dead an attempt escape as cp 682 vs
scp-017
could the shadow person be up to the
task of finally consigning the hard to
destroy reptile to eternal darkness
let's find out the shadow person is a
small figure roughly the size and shape
of a human child with the ability to
absorb other entities and make them
disappear by simply coming into contact
with their shadows it consumed a tissue
sample from scp-682 with no issues so
the tests proceeded however during the
full test
scp-682 roared in a horrible rage
causing scp-01 to stumble and retreat
back to the corner of the cell it
refused to come near scp-682
to this day it's unclear whether the
sound hurt 017 or merely frightened it
scp-682 vs scp-743
could the world's most terrifying
chocolate fountain filled with an
endless supply of omnivorous insects
finally be the thing to fell the hard to
destroy reptile initially there seemed
to be hope exactly as the foundation
intended 682 consumed some of the
delicious chocolate marking it for death
by the nightmarish creatures lurking
within the swarm soon burst from the
fountain and began attacking and
devouring scp-682
the creatures consumed 21 percent of
682's mass before the monster finally
fought back it evolved a long
anteater-like tongue that it used to
catch and eat many of the insects the
insects and 682 fed off of each other
for days and after the two were
separated having consumed 743's
chocolate appeared to have temporarily
given 682 heightened regenerative
abilities after observing this the
researchers concluded that the two
anomalies should never be brought into
contact again
scp-682 vs scp-3108
the hard to destroy reptile may treat
all regular firearms like mere
annoyances but could the legendary
nerfing gun take the monster down a peg
or two the nerfing gun has the power to
turn anything it shoots into a worse
version of itself a d-class was ordered
to shoot 682 with it and after missing
six times due to fear he landed the
lucky seventh shot but it wasn't so
lucky 682 became larger stronger and
developed the ability to explode and
reconstitute itself immediately as an
offensive weapon it breached containment
and killed many members of personnel
researcher western theorized that 682
became a more dangerous version of
itself because a weaker more docile
version of 682 would be considered a net
positive by the scp foundation and
therefore wouldn't technically be making
it worse that's one dangerous
technicality
scp-682 versus scp-1933
who would win a huge hyper-intelligent
lizard monster who can not only adapt to
almost any attacks but also give them
back or a fat drunk guy dressed as santa
with irish cream for blood though to be
fair this irish cream will also turn
your blood into irish cream and kill you
foundation researchers siphoned off 200
gallons and fed it to
scp-682 682 apparently really enjoyed
this because it drank literally all of
it even becoming intoxicated and
collapsing onto the ground vocalizing
loudly researchers hoped this fluid was
wrecking havoc on 682's internals but
instead it vomited up huge quantities of
this anomalous irish cream turning the
walls of its cell into irish cream and
subsequently escaping to go on another
deadly rampage happy holidays i guess
scp-682 vs
scp-063 the hard to destroy reptile
faced the ultimate weapon a toothbrush
known as the world's best toothbrush
which can cleave through any physical
matter the foundation used a robotic arm
to attack 682 with a toothbrush
scrubbing out 20 of its body before it
began regenerating however the
regenerated matter seemed to be immune
to 063 and 682 then attacked and
destroyed the robotic arm 0-6-3 scrubbed
its way through the ground and out of
the containment chamber 682 grew a long
prehensile arm that slithered down
through the hole and killed two
researchers 0-6-3 was later covered
without incident delegating a high
priority task to a person who only
delivers a bare minimum style of work
ethic otherwise will probably result in
the task not getting done the foundation
tried to snuff out scp-682 with the help
of scp-2599
formerly known as xena cho a woman of
korean descent who will carry out any
order you give her but only around
halfway that's why the foundation
ordered her to attack 682 until it was
200 dead so even if she only did her
task by halves it would still be 100
dead by all accounts she was actually
doing a pretty solid job horrifically
mutilating the creature to the point of
near death when it suddenly yelled kill
me you psycho organs do it and that
order seemingly confused her seeing as
only going halfway on killing the
creature was something she'd already
done she remained motionless in the test
chamber until she was physically removed
and later attempts to use her in 682's
termination were fruitless
scp-682 vs scp-36
when the scp foundation tested
scp-3660 the zoo zipper a zipper that
hollows creatures out and turns their
insides into an animal against scp-682
the hard to destroy reptile they were
hoping to minimize the monster the
zipper was placed against the creature
while it slept and left in place within
seven minutes it did its thing unzipping
682 and turning its body into dead
rubber only a tiny gecko with 682's mind
came out of the mess confused and angry
researcher gentler entered the
containment chamber and stomped on the
682 gecko sadly this didn't work out the
682 gecko suddenly became 682's regular
size while still retaining its gecko
appearance and ate researcher jetler
before breaching containment and killing
several more people 682 returned to its
normal appearance over the next two
weeks test failed mother nature isn't
something you should mess with and the
same goes with her daughter this is
scp-682 vs scp-166
this teenage nature sprite was put
head-to-head with scp-682 the hard to
describe reptile in a test conducted by
dr trelmakshoth as scp-682 attacked her
its body melted away into a patch of
grass with flowers sprouting out of it
however within 15 minutes it began
regenerating as quickly as it had first
melted into a version of itself briefly
covered in flowers and mushrooms it even
sprouted a whole tree out of its back
breaking the test chamber's ceiling dr
tromiksov may need to pay to get that
repaired ready for this one
scp-682 vs scp-835 is one of the most
horrifying scp-682 cross tests we have
logged to date that's right we have
paired the hard to destroy reptile with
the disgusting nightmare known as
scp-835 a giant carnivorous coral polyp
made from living human matter when
scp-835 was released the infectious
abomination pulled scp-682 into its
massive gullet dragging it down for a
slow and painful digestion surrounded by
the intense pressure and screaming human
faces of the beast's fleshy throat what
was eventually ejected was little more
than 682's skeleton however over time
the skeleton regenerated into a horrific
hybrid of scp-682 and
scp-835 covered in sticky tentacles
human faces spewing acid and infectious
spores that could turn others into
monsters it breached containment and
killed many the survivors had to be
terminated to avoid scp-835
contamination spreading further in one
cross test the foundation thought
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
would bite off more than it could chew
with scp-807
a deadly plate from the last chance
diner this plate makes any food placed
on it extra delicious but also makes
them extra unhealthy so unhealthy that
people who eat its food tend to die of
massive heart attacks they use the plate
to transmute two scp-682 specials a mix
of 10 kilograms of rotten meat and
sharpened bone splinters 10 liters of
rancid mayonnaise 1 liter potassium
cyanide and 1 kilogram morphine
hydrochloride considered a 5 star course
for our pal scp-682
and fed it to the beast at first it
seemed immobile perhaps the monster had
been bested but when d-classes entered
to check the creature's skin ruptured in
several areas ejecting high-pressure
jets of its own blood in every direction
killing them all the reptile was
completely fine afterward and eagerly
ate a third 682 special it's the clash
of the titans
scp-682 the hard-to-destroy reptile vs
scp-096
the terrifying murderous shy guy but who
won this battle well it was kind of a
draw their battle lasted for 72 whole
hours and ended in a brutal stalemate
with scp-096 severely injured and
huddled in one corner of the room and
682 in the other missing 85 percent of
its original body mass the creatures
were both brought back to their chambers
with relative ease a fight like this can
never happen again because now whenever
096 is brought too close to 682 it turns
away shrieks and begins clawing at its
own face who would win the hard to
destroy reptile or 9.15 million
kilograms of bananas this is scp-682 vs
scp-3521
when scp-682 was cross-tested with
scp-3521
a little yellow pill that makes bananas
manifest in the stomach of those who eat
them the foundation hoped to answer that
question 682 was tricked into eating the
pill by hiding it inside the body of a
dead cow which was then fed to the
monster as time passed an absurd number
of bananas began to manifest in and
around scp-682
filling its containment chamber and then
the entire facility however just when it
seems 682 was crushed under all that
potassium it began eating the bananas
faster than they could be produced and
because bananas are each slightly
naturally radioactive eating that many
gave scp-682 the ability to fire a
powerful radiation beam out of its mouth
until 3521's effects were off the
craziest part this all occurred within a
10 minute period guess you could say
things when a little bananas there in
one cross test
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile was
made to face off against
scp-1361 a giant aggressive mass of
animal slurry that envelops and digests
everything it touches before briefly
taking on their traits just over 1 000
kilograms of
scp-1361 was poured onto scp-682
and it successfully enveloped the
creature the problem was that it then
began taking on traits and a temperament
incredibly similar to scp-682
after developing legs jaws and other
physical features similar to the reptile
it broke out of containment and killed
17 members of staff after several failed
attempts to stop the creature with small
arms fire it was finally destroyed by
the aerial deployment of napalm 682
skeletal carcass was retrieved from
within and placed back in its chamber it
had regenerated back to perfect health
within a mere six hours